[Music]
Battle Royale games breed twitch
superstars whether it's dr. Lupo T foo
or ninja the Battle Royale genre has
turned a handful of truly talented
gamers into renowned competitors and
sometimes actual celebrities tyler ninja
Blevins how do I call you ninja - I call
you Tyler 27 year old gaming sensation
Tyler ninja Blevins one of the most
popular players to come here and teach
me please welcome ninja following the
release of apex legend the newest Battle
Royale on the scene all eyes were on the
game's first official tournament twitch
rivals where twitches most popular
streamers compete against one another
and surprising no one ninja and King
Richard both be our veterans took the
tournament what was surprising is that
they weren't the ones getting all the
praise when the tournament ended instead
all eyes were the up-and-coming streamer
they've been paired with an 18 year old
who've been grinding every day since
apex legends launched Kobe dizzy meadows
all right dude sometimes just kind of
magically make it away and survive in
less than a month busy has gone from an
everyday kid to living the twitch dream
he's become one of the game's first
professional players twitch his newest
breakout star and ultimately apex is
first Legend shout out the bucket dizzy
this kids a legend prior to disease
explosive entrance onto Kings Canyon
he spent the better part of the year
trying to make it as a counter-strike
player despite earning spots on multiple
teams including selfless in gaming he
never quite made it big still his talent
didn't go unrecognized
bro do you know if that dizzy is the
same dizzy that used to play like CI
yeah yeah and he was mad young right
yeah okay yeah he's always been in
saying that every like shooter that I've
played with him you know like what
battalion came out I was super into it
and he was into it and it was just like
we were just screams and [ __ ] like he's
super competitive he reminds me of Brad
he's a legend for sure his good bye
September 2017 Disney started to break
into streaming playing both
counter-strike and fortnight Ari Disney
House your life shading you I'm doing
good
nothing much really in this [ __ ]
school and [ __ ] it's so boring
next season mark my words battle past
year 100 season level 100 extreme our
times of the whole season 7 a thousand
hours streaming and then on February 4th
2019 apex legends came out and
immediately people were looking at it as
a true challenge the fortnight's place
as the biggest PR in the world and like
every other streamer Disney was there on
day one but unlike everyone else dizzy
was exceptional
[Music]
housing as foes as soon as he got his
hands on a Texas Legends dizzy went
crazy
he was so absurdly good at the game that
just a week after it came out and our ge
sports scientist turning him into one of
the game's first professional players he
also set in the solo kill world record
achieving 33 eliminations in a single
match
let's [ __ ] go dude let's [ __ ] go
33 that's it well record that's actually
well record I'm pretty sure 32 is go
record that's [ __ ] 33 then came time
for Apex legends first official
tournament which rivals collected a lot
of the popular streamers and pitted them
against one another along with his
energy teammate King Richard Disney was
paired up with ninja the most famous
streamer in the world and the winner of
the first official tournament for every
major BR released to date but with four
hours to accumulate as many points as
possible and $50,000 at stake
it wasn't ninja who carried the squad
there's a whole team on me
any of a man team
oh my god I was nasty
easy dude I got absolutely right so I
got a wingman
is easy
all that all that all three all three in
front of me
that's my main
let's go let's go I like 54 today I ate
the whole server as the tournament came
to a close Disney had amassed roughly
200 kills 50 more than shroud and put
his team in a position to take first
when it came down to the final two
squads Disney was often forced to hunt
his way to victory since the other
squads kept running away from them
we need the skills
let's merely last merely laughs let's go
finally I swear I drowned marathon I'm
not even kidding the competition between
first and second was tight and it wasn't
immediately clear who come out on top
but in the end dizzy King Richard and
ninja won with a single point and it was
almost entirely thanks to dizzy we have
a winner we don't know who it is
they haven't told us we're gonna be
surprised you guys gonna be surprised I
want to know who what is my god what I
learned about dizzy is like this kid is
the fastest player on the planet right
now an apex she can't keep up with them
so he finds kills he's gonna slay them
you end up not finding people to fight
because he's killing everybody shout out
to [ __ ] it dizzy by the way for being
absolutely insane as kids a legend he's
really good he's a really good good
gamer a true gamer natural talent later
that week Disney led his squad to a
first place finish in the $20,000
CodeRed tournament where in the grand
finals Disney put up as many kills as
the entire opposing team since then he's
solidified himself as the game's single
most sensational player
Wow oh my god oh my god
this one oh my god I got maggots on my
body dude sometime just kind of
magically make it away and survive why
are we play with him he's gonna take all
shops him now in just one month
Disney has gone from an everyday pug
star to international twitch celebrity
after years of struggling to find
success in Counter Strike and fortnight
his one month of playing apex Legends
has skyrocketed him to fame a lot of
kids were talented gamers dream of one
day making it big and Disney is living
that dream since respawn has yet to make
any announcements regarding the future
of apex eSports scene no one is really
sure where it might go but one thing is
for sure dizzy is here to stay
[Music]
good lord
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]